[Музика]
привіт учні 9 класу, мене звати Амна,
і ось сьогодні урок англійської мови,
ми продовжимо розмову про
молодіжні організації та клуби, тож давайте
познайомимося з людиною, яка насправді є
учасником одного з молодіжних  клуб,
це Мелані, і ви можете бачити, що
Мелані 15 років, вона є
членом вуличного молодіжного клубу в Уортон
Ланкашир, Великобританія, тому їй подобається
ходити в клуб, тому що вона може бачити
там своїх друзів, їм подобається
грати в клубних ноутбуках  онлайн ігри Джулія
не любить грати в настільний теніс,
але іноді грає у футбол і також
вправляється грати на барабанах у клубі,
тому насправді, як ви розумієте,
молодіжний клуб – це щось більше про
таланти студентів і більше про
спілкування з однолітками  тож давайте
подивимося на кілька запитань, які
насправді допоможуть нам трохи
більше дізнатися про молодіжні клуби, тож
перший молодіжний клуб, які молодіжні клуби ви
знаєте в Україні, які чи  організації допомагають
дітям та студентам розвивати свої
таланти, щоб розвивати себе, а що щодо
іншої британської молодіжної
організації, яку ви знаєте,
про деякі з них ми говорили на минулому
уроці, тож чи можете ви пригадати щось
із попереднього уроку інформацію,
яку ви отримали, а потім подумайте про це
номер третій чи належите ви до якогось молодіжного
клубу і що вас цікавить
діяльності клубів, коли я був у
школі, я насправді був учасником
різних молодіжних
клубів мистецький клуб театральний клуб музичний клуб
і так далі як щодо вас номер чотири,
які молодіжні клуби б  ти хочеш приєднатися до
яких видів діяльності ти б хотів
там займатися чим ти більше хочеш займатися
спортом можливо ти б хотів піти в
похід куди однолітки зі студентами,
з якими ти навчаєшся, то як щодо тебе, до
яких клубів ти б хотів приєднатися
добре  тепер наше завдання прочитати
інформацію про молодіжні клуби, а потім
ми повинні будемо відповісти на запитання
після тексту, щоб ми  прочитайте
про молодіжні клуби, скільки часу вони
вже були тут, у світі, і
ми дізнаємося про різні молодіжні
клуби і чому вони насправді
важливі для молоді, тож давайте
почнемо читати, що молодіжні клуби
існують вже більше 150 років
види діяльності, які вони пропонують, можливо, трохи змінилися,
але їх мета залишилася
майже незмінною. 1863 року священик Артур Світман,
вчитель і єпископ Англіканської церкви,
сказав, що молодіжні клуби надавали вечірній
відпочинок, а також
розважальну, але корисну літературу,
корисні інструкції та сильний керівний
вплив на молодь.  люди вперед
і вгору в соціальному та моральному плані,
мова може бути старомодною, але молодіжні
клуби все ще зосереджуються на тих самих життєво важливих
речах сьогодні,
що є молодіжними клубами.
Приналежність до діяльності та підтримка
керівників клубів та волонтерів дозволяють
молодим людям опановувати нові навички та
розвиватися  впевненість і стійкість до
майбутнього, а також веселощі молоді люди
вибирають туди з молодіжними клубами, відкритими
для всіх молодих людей, а
в Англії існує близько одинадцяти тисяч молодіжних клубів,
що ви думаєте
про молодіжні клуби, які пропонують там величезний спектр
заходів  чи все, від
боксу до танців, а також клуби,
зосереджені на навколишньому середовищі, творче
мистецтво та відносини лідерства та робочих навичок
також є центром
молодіжних клубів як з друзями, так і з
дорослими, які працюють там для деяких молодих
людей, їхні стосунки з їхнім
молодіжним працівником або  волонтер у клубі може
бути єдиним значущим стосунком, який вони
мають із дорослою молоддю. Клуби мають
унікальну роль і мають бути дійсними
та підтримуваними, оскільки вони можуть значно
змінити життя багатьох молодих
людей у своїх гр
мадах.  теплий безпечний дружній
простір для молодих людей, який, як вони кажуть,
вони хочуть, це може дати їм реальну владу
та володіння. Це може бути місце, де
вони розвивають нові навички пробують нові
речі, де їх бачать і оцінюють
інакше, ніж у школі чи вдома,
де цінують їхні таланти і
де вони можуть розважитися. Молодіжні клуби
пропонують щось для кожного,
важливо, щоб кожна молода людина мала
доступ до правильного клубу  для них
зараз ми закінчили читати текст,
і ви знаєте трохи більше про
молодіжні організації та клуби, а тепер давайте
перевіримо, що саме ви пам’ятаєте, що ви повинні
відповісти на питання номер один
молодіжні клуби існують вже
більше 200 років B 1500  років C 150
років, тож які цифри ви запам'ятаєте,
яке число є правильним,
безумовно, це C, тому молодіжні клуби
існують понад 150 років,
молодіжні клуби дають молодим людям дешеві
розваги після школи,
це правда чи неправда чи це  не
згадується взагалі в тексті, тож що
ви пам’ятаєте
, насправді було щось
згадане про дешеві розваги
після школи для молоді  люди в молодіжних
клубах, тож варіант C безсумнівно
неправильний, тому ми маємо лише правдивий чи хибний,
так чи правда, що вони пропонують молодим
людям дешеві розваги
після школи
три
в Англії налічується близько десяти тисяч одинадцять тисяч одна тисяча одинадцять тисяч молодіжних клубів, тож ви
пам'ятаєте, скільки молодіжних клубів в
Англії, тож однозначно відповідь
буде одинадцять тисяч, оскільки молодіжні
клуби пропонують лише підліткам розвивати
свої таланти спілкування не є  дуже
цінується там, тому ще раз вірно,
неправда чи не згадано, чи ця
інформація згадана в тексті
насправді так, ви можете знайти деяку
інформацію про
спілкування молоді з іншими молодими людьми
та дорослими ми також можемо знайти
інформацію про студентів та дітей, які
розвивають свої таланти, але  чи правда,
що спілкування не дуже
важливо для молодіжних клубів, це
однозначно  false Насправді,
студентам і підліткам
важливо спілкуватися, коли вони вступають до молодіжних
клубів, добре, і п’яте питання
тут лише для того, щоб ви особисто подумали,
що ви думаєте про
важливість молодіжних клубів для молоді,
оскільки ви  молоді люди, що ви
вважаєте важливим, чи важливо
для вас вступати до молодіжного клубу, які
переваги ви можете отримати від цього, тому я
думаю, що це досить цікава
річ, і це дуже важлива
організація, як і кожен молодіжний клуб, такий
важливий для  молоді люди
спілкуватися, щоб працювати разом і
розвивати свої таланти добре, а
тепер давайте подивимося на фотографії,
які насправді ілюструють деякі
види діяльності, які можна проводити в
молодіжних клубах, у яких заходах ви
хотіли б брати участь і чому так беруть
подивившись на фотографії на першому, ми
насправді бачимо людей у каное, тож, бе
перечно, це клуб, який сп
ямований на розвиток деяких фізичних навичок та
ця діяльність називається веслування на каное або
байдарках. Ви б
хотіли зайнятися каякингом.
Ви б хотіли спробувати
покататися на роликах, тож я думаю, що ви зробите
третій малюнок тут, ми можемо побачити урок мистецтва,
люди можуть навчитися малювати, як
малювати та як створювати
вироби ручної роботи, а як щодо іншого
верхнього правого кута дівчини насправді
звичайне Lego, але це не тільки для розваги
та ігор, це насправді проект Lego,
тому діти використовують Lego для науково-
технічної інженерії та математики
, це дуже цікава річ, тому
я думаю, що вам було б дуже
корисно дізнатися трохи  більше про
цю діяльність в Інтернеті, а
останнє внизу праворуч ми
можемо побачити стіл з деякими фігурами та
деякими речами, що це,
безперечно, настільна гра  Саме
це DND або Dungeons & Dragons одна з
найвідоміших настільних ігор у всьому
світі, тому молодіжні клуби настільних ігор також
існують, тож, якщо ви хочете приєднатися до них, вам
просто потрібно їх знайти, а тепер
давайте подивимося на  тут речення,
і нашим завданням буде заповнити
пропуски правильними формами дієслів
у дужках. Наше завдання досить просте, нам
потрібно використовувати герундій, який є ing,
або інфінітив, який дорівнює 2 + дієслово, тому
давайте подивимося
на перше речення  Шеріл забула принести
свій гаманець, тому я позичив їй 10 доларів, тож вона
забула принести, чи вона забула
принести сюди, нам потрібно використати
інфінітив, вона забула принести свій гаманець,
тому вона зараз не має його тут, а як
щодо другого,
я  зовсім забув прийти сюди, коли я
був дитиною,
але тепер я пам'ятаю, що мої батьки привели мене
сюди, коли мені було три, тому я зовсім
забув прийти або я зовсім забув
прийти сюди ми говоримо про
спогади минулі дії та спогади минулого, які
ми будемо використовувати  інж  тут ми
повинні сказати, що я зовсім забув
прийти сюди, коли я був дитиною номер
три Лідія дійсно шкодує, що кинула
школу, їй справді довелося
боротися, щоб заробити на життя через
це рішення, тому ми будемо використовувати ing
dropping або інфінітив до  киньте сюди,
нам потрібно використати ing, вона шкодує про те, що
кинула школу, тому ми
говоримо про минулі дії, минула
подія тут номер чотири Я шкодую повідомляти
вам, що Mr.  Сміт помер, тому
інформуючи або щоб повідомити, у цьому випадку нам
потрібно буде використати інфінітив, тому я з
жалем повідомляю вам, що наступний
номер п'ять,
чи ви пам'ятаєте, зібрали купальник,
якщо ви можете, наша відпустка на Гаваях буде не дуже веселою
не йди плавати, то ти не
згадав пакувати речі чи пам’ятав
пакувати речі тут, нам потрібно буде використати
інфінітив, звичайно, ти не пам’ятав
пакувати номер шість
, ти пам’ятаєш, що застряг у тому
ліфті, коли ми були в Нью-Йорку, я
думав, що ми  ніколи не виходь звідти,
тож ти пам’ятаєш бути чи
пам’ятаєш, що
був тут, нам потрібно буде використовувати ing,
оскільки ми говоримо про пам’ять, тож ти
пам’ятаєш, як застрягли в тому ліфті в
Нью-Йорку номер сім, якщо не можеш
знайдіть ключ, спробуйте відкрити або спробуйте відкрити
замок чимось іншим, наприклад, ножем
чи викруткою, тож я і G або два плюс
інфінітив, як ви думаєте, що тут
нам потрібно використовувати I і G число
вісім останній тут
вона  намагалася сказати йому жахливу правду,
але вона джу  Ст не могла змусити себе це
зробити, щоб сказати чи сказати, що, на твою
думку, добре, звичайно, має бути
інфінітив, тому вона спробувала сказати йому
жахливу правду, добре, так що ти можеш запитати "
добре" до плюс інфінітив, але тут ми
маємо  ті самі дієслова в номері один і
номер два ми маємо для Бога в обох випадках,
але тоді ми маємо a і G в номері два
і маємо інфінітив у номері один,
то в чому може бути різниця, і те
саме стосується решти
речень  наприклад, regrets dropping regret,
щоб повідомити, яка різниця тут
це те саме дієслово, але різні
структури, наступні за цим дієсловом, тому в
номері п'ять те саме пам'ятайте про шлях
запам'ятайте існування і спробуйте відкрити і спробуйте
розповісти в номерах сім і вісім, а тепер
давайте з'ясуємо про  різниця, тому за
цими дієсловами насправді може слідувати
або герундій, або інфінітив, але
різниця полягає в тому, що є різниця у значенні,
тож давайте подивимося, чи ми
використовуємо запам’ятати з ing з герундієм,
ми поговоримо про щось  я пам'ятаю, що ми
робили в минулому, так що це
вже спогад, наприклад,
я пам'ятаю, як ходив на пляж, коли
був дитиною, тому я пам'ятаю, як ходив
на пляж, коли був молодим,
о, якумо курама, брате, мій нещодавно
захист підіуму  на Готама мубарак джаваді
пам'ятай ing yap Amiata
yaki is de la plage kullaberg de Tenorio
я пам'ятаю, як пішов на пляж, де
ти будеш згадувати плюс 2 плюс інфінітив, коли
ми думаємо про щось, що нам потрібно зробити,
наприклад, я згадав купити молоко, так що
так  є хлопець та її доларовий магазин
ative не впорається з малока доктор.
Міллер розігрівся, читаючи свинячий ніс королівства Шанель,
Роберта,
тому я йшов додому, і
мені в голову прийшла ідея, що мені потрібне молоко, тому я
купив його,
щоб ви відчули різницю, яку я
пам'ятаю, коли ходив на пляж у минулому,
це моя пам'ять і  Я пам’ятаю занадто
багато, щоб купити молоко – це те, що мені
потрібно зробити наступну пару дієслів,
це забути плюс герундій і забути плюс
2 плюс інфінітив, давайте подивимося
на різницю між цими,
тож забудьте плюс ing або забудьте плюс герундій
це  протилежність запам'ятати плюс
герундій oujet сказати Антонія не пам'ятати
плюс ing,
коли ми забуваємо про спогад, коли ми
щось не можемо згадати, коли ми не можемо
згадати, що робили, ми скажемо,
що ми забули зробити щось,
що ми зробили в  минуле більше не
в нашій пам'яті подивіться на приклад
чи ми справді вивчали цю тему, перш ніж
я зовсім забув читати про це
Четта Панетта еквісетум з халіфа
Чилі янкі Джоанна Мозес її тато
так поні  - zaboo yak sharapov
господиня вище prot Sir Jana permeate
острів Мен і amaya a UK, який говорив я
зробив з
фільму Amo про амо забути плюс герундій, а
про забути плюс 2 плюс інфінітив ми
будемо використовувати цю
структуру, щоб говорити про протилежність
запам'ятати + 2  + інфінітив, тому коли ми
хотіли щось зробити, але ми забуваємо
про це, ніби є потреба, але ми
цього не зробили, наприклад, я забув
подзвонити мамі
так, бик відкриває Хуаніта, мама,
знову перестановка ванільна мама
Asama mini petite  благородний відкриває Хуаніта
мама куля каже Роберта, тому я
хотів зателефонувати мамі, але
коли мені було добре подзвонити
їй, я забув, і я цього не зробив, тому
це різниця тут із забути +
герундій  ми говорили про минулі спогади, ми
чогось не пам'ятаємо, і за допомогою забути
+ до інфінітиву ми поговоримо про
речі, які нам потрібно було зробити, але ми
цього не зробили, тому ми забули про
них наступна пара дієслів try + герундій тому,
коли  ми намагаємося щось робити  Насправді це
означає, що ми виконуємо різні
варіанти завдання і намагаємося зробити щось нове,
ми намагаємося провести експеримент, лікар, час мого
експерименту був погана пам’ять, заглушення
пристрою, проблема
каже Роберто або застряг у звичайній каструлі
придумати рушій, який
намагається + ing  подивіться на приклад, як вона
спробувала відмовитися від шоколаду, але це не
допомогло їй схуднути, лікар, коли,
ймовірно, Овід Мовіда Сміт Шоколад, о,
нам потрібна послуга la la skinnet Abajo
це edamame ha ha ha bui експеримент Ніккі,
на жаль, не був таким успішним
однак тут ми будемо використовувати форму ing,
коли ми говоримо про
складні речі, які важко зробити,
тоді ми будемо використовувати спробу + інфінітив, тому,
наприклад, я спробую нести валізу,
але для мене він виглядає занадто важким, тому я  думаю,
мені буде важко
нести валізу томонага будда
башко ламінує буддійська хмара знати,
чи був це V Напрям хвар мо про ваш
Кіста загін мр.  примусовий Деніел ой-йо
хо поширений девіз Будда
яваді Діас лава спробувати нескінченно навіть
спробувати зробити щось
добре наступна пара дієслів жаліти плюс
герундій і жаліти плюс інфінітив,
яка різниця тут, коли ми
шкодуємо про те, що робимо щось таке жалюгідне, як
герундій, це означає  що ми шкодуємо про
те, що ми робили в минулому,
Оптимус Кодомо, захист був бунтівником
гною. Мо не виключати, що вона шкодує про те, що
залишила школу, коли їй було 16, вона
хотіла б, щоб вона більше вчилася, а
потім пішла до університету або японська, щоб
перейти до посібника із захисту  up візуалізує
коледж, вона не рокер, у мене
будуть автомобілі, якщо це в Лі, тож
коли нам повідомляють комусь погані новини та
в офіційному вигляді,
ми будемо використовувати структуру жаль + 2
+ інфінітив, наприклад, я шкодую  щоб
повідомити вам, що поїзд затримується,
компанія з жалем повідомляє місце,
що лондонський офіс закриється наступного
року, тому це офіційний спосіб
донести погані новини  тому шкодувати робити
щось шкодувати, щоб сказати або розповісти
щось, буде використовуватися саме в цьому
значенні ok, і остання пара тут
stop stop герундій і stop + інфінітив,
коли ми взагалі припиняємо щось робити, це
означає, що дієслово в герундію
говорить, що  ми зупинилися і закінчили
робити щось назавжди або зупинилися в
цей момент, наприклад, була пожежна
сигналізація, тому я перестав їсти і вийшов на
вулицю
ba la putana trabajo Tomoya berestov
super nibsy п'єдестал з переліком бажань
роману, його власний лікар поклоняється
Муджі чесний  тому в цьому випадку ми використовуємо
stop + ing, коли ми говоримо, що ми зупиняємося, щоб
щось зробити, це означає, що ми виконуємо
якусь діяльність, потім робимо паузу,
ми виконуємо іншу діяльність, а потім
продовжуємо попередню
О Джей Шарма Будда Махабхарата
протеа Акума робо-мо  мій robo-moe лапи
канонади див. CAG Перікл я змія
був застрахований чесний підхід у бідності
посол тато готовий зробити моє дно на
Cassata зупинитись щось робити не запис
вона була шоппі  ng і вона зупинилася,
щоб випити чашку кави,
а потім вона продовжила робити покупки,
наприклад, тому вона припинила покупки, тому що
вона хотіла отримати чашку кави, це
не означає, що вона закінчила покупки
на той день,
ні, вона просто призупинила покупки з чашкою
кави і продовжила ходити по магазинах
порівняти ці два приклади
Кейт перестала привітатися з Мері проти
Кейт зупинилася, щоб привітатися з Мері,
яка різниця в першому,
скаже Кейт Перес Тала vittatus, як Мері
взяла купюру Шевенінген Ендрюс в
абрикосі з дрю  монопод кухар Кейт
цукіні Ліза Флетчер Наталі магазини
Кезада приватна Мері Доктор venetie
pedroka Кейт Дез Ашла краснуха
zipangu приватна Аліса Мері низька тележка,
тож це відмінності між
дієсловами, за якими може супроводжуватися герундій або
інфінітив із зміною значення, а тепер
давайте попрактикуємося  наше завдання - поставити
дієслово в герундій або інфінітив
з бути уважним до
контексту речень були щільні овал
безконтактні st  підхід до поривання Івана
намаха вода давайте почнемо з номера 1 я
не міг заснути, тому я спробував випити гарячого
молока, тож ось це експеримент чи
це щось складне,
цей експеримент, тож ми будемо
використовувати ing я спробував випити гарячого молока
номер 2 вона намагалася дотягнутися до книги
на високій полиці, але вона була занадто маленькою, тому
їй було
важко дістатися до книги чи це був лише
експеримент, який ми можемо припустити, якщо людина
була занадто
маленькою, тому невисокою  достатньо, щоб дістати книгу
з високої полиці, яку ми використаємо, щоб досягти
інфінітиву, це означатиме, що ми
говоримо про щось складне, ой,
просто перемістіть мій дорогоцінний квадроцикл, зараз з
брукованими підгузками, дами люблять плем'я
з maserati, інфінітив номер три, ви
повинні перестати курити  це не корисно для вашого
здоров'я, тому, якщо це не корисно для вашого
здоров'я, вам, мабуть, слід кинути це, щоб
назавжди закінчити займатися цією діяльністю, у
цьому значенні ми будемо використовувати ing кинути
палити, але з часом
супер-приємні викиди ohon ara  бік номер
чотири ми припинили навчання, тому що ми були
втомлені, тому ми припинили навчання, тому що ми
були втомлені, тому ми будемо використовувати навчання
знову
але зараз ми закінчуємо вивчати номер п'ять,
вони перестануть обідати о 12, тож,
ймовірно, вони працюватимуть, а о 12
вони отримають обід, тож тут ми
будемо використовувати 2 плюс інфінітив вони
перестануть обідати о 12 1 призначений
паном магазинчиком  be dirty or vinod cg номер
о ні, я забув купити молоко, тож ми
говоримо про пам'ять чи ми
говоримо про щось, що нам потрібно,
щоб зробити, про те, що нам
потрібно зробити, але забув зробити це тут,
ми будемо використовувати  2 плюс інфінітив Я
забув купити молоко так, книга могла б помістити
малоку, а як щодо числа 7,
будь ласка, не забудьте взяти сік
по дорозі додому, у нас така сама
ситуація, ми говоримо про щось
важливе, тому не варто  забудьте вибрати NASA
b  oot показує стрічку і є лампочки
з сита номер 8 ми почали
це, перш ніж я забув,
вивчити це о, і тут ми говоримо про
пам'ять не про щось важливе, що нам
потрібно зробити, а про те, що ми пам'ятаємо з
минулого, тут ми будемо використовувати  ing Я
забув, вивчаючи це так Абу Ахмед безпечний
чилі Джанна Памір втомився Сохо Донна рухатися
стати Буддою Мазераті
ing номер дев'ять,
будь ласка, пам'ятайте, принесіть домашнє завдання, тому,
будь ласка, не забудьте взяти з собою домашнє завдання
або принесіть сюди ми говоримо про
нагадування, тому нам потрібно буде використати  що до
плюс інфінітив Будда Ласка Несса
bootprint Aston damash новини про dyna pam
все ж я повинен пробачити я сподіваюся, що
гніздо
Madonna movie bottom of Jemima 2 +
infinitive this idea Слава пам'ятати
наступний номер 10 я пам'ятаю, як ходив на
пляж у дитинстві так  ми мали дуже
подібне речення в одному з попередніх
пояснень, я сподіваюся, що ви його пам'ятаєте
, тому тут ми говоримо про
спогади з минулого, ми будемо використовувати те, що
я пам'ятаю, до  пляж у
дитинстві наступний номер 11 Я шкодую сказати
вам, що поїзд затримується, тому
це, ймовірно, формальний спосіб повідомити
комусь погані новини, у цьому випадку ми
будемо використовувати 2 + інфінітив, тому давайте
перевіримо, я шкодую про  сказати тобі, що
потяг затримується і останній
номер 12 я шкодую розповісти Джулі свою таємницю
тепер вона сказала всім грати в яшку
чи вона встала козлов Julie secret is eros
Minaya ho rasca solo
you see Oh jamika demo proquest moon
ology of dona  moça park на моєму maserati
i ng, тому я шкодую, що сказав Джулі свій секрет,
добре зроблено, дуже дякую
за вашу відданість, а тепер давайте
подивимося, яке ваше домашнє завдання
на наступний урок, тож ваше домашнє завдання –
скласти власне  речення, які
ви думаєте, використовуючи структури, які
ми щойно практикували, тому це забути плюс
інфінітив забути плюс герундій запам'ятати
плюс інфінітив запам'ятати плюс герундій
стоп плюс інфінітив стоп плюс герундій
жаль плюс інфінітив жаль плюс
ge  rund і Troy був інфінітив спробуйте плюс
герундій, будь ласка, будьте уважні, коли ви
складаєте речення, пам'ятайте, що існує
різниця в значеннях, коли ви використовуєте
інфінітив або герундій після цих
дієслів, тому будьте уважні робіть домашнє завдання
дякую за увагу і
до зустрічі  час
[музика]
ви